PROFESSOR: So OK, what
did we do last time?
Thanks for coming
back by the way.
So last time, we
did MDS codes.
MDS codes, and we
looked at this.
And we derived some generic
properties of these things if
they existed.
And then eventually, we moved
to Reed-Solomon codes.
And so indeed, they exist.
We talked a little bit about
existence altogether, the main
conjection, MDS codes,
I just wrote it down.
And like I said, you
want to be rich and
famous, solve this.
There's people doing geometry
in math that would be
deliriously happy if
you solved it.
So if for nothing else.
So the last thing I wrote down
last time was something about
a matrix which somebody
recognized as some Fourier
transform matrix.
And that's where I want to pick
up here, at least quickly
make that connection.
So let me rewrite the definition
of Reed-Solomon
codes again.
And so a Reed-Solomon code,
the way we defined it last
time was all field elements,
we would evaluate the
polynomial in all
field elements.
Now we do it slightly
different.
Let me make it Solomon-Stein
in order to denote that
difference.
And let's say this is
beta 0, beta n.
So that's the old definition.
Only the, let's say, the beta 0,
beta 1, up to beta n, they
are the non-zero elements now.
And just for the heck of it, so
we talked about punctured
Reed-Solomon codes last
time that it would
still be MDS codes.
So nothing has changed there.
In particular, all the arguments
would be the same.
In particular, just to humor me,
let's say beta i is omega
to the i, where omega
is primitive in Fq.
So what that means, you remember
that primitive means
that the powers of omega
cycle through all
the non-zero elements.
Remember the non-zero elements
are a multiplicative group.
And it's a cyclic group.
And it's the generator
of the group.
Good.
So once we write it like this,
we can actually write down the
whole Reed-Solomon code in some
sort of transfer domain
description in the Fourier
transform.
And the way this goes
is the following.
So from now on, I will make
implicit identification
without making them.
So this is an identification
which I
just jump around between.
A vector --
so this one would be a Fqn.
And Fx would be maybe
0 to MDS 1.
Let's leave it at that.
So I make this --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's make
this identification free.
It's just a vector of length n
and a polynomial of length n.
And so whenever I want this
to have a low degree, the
polynomial, then I just
write that expression.
So this identification
we make freely now.
And then how can we write F?
Let F now be code word in
the Reed-Solomon code.
And then I say Fi.
What is Fi?
The i is element.
Well, we know that this is
F of omega to the i.
So this is, at the moment,
counted from 0.
So this is --
you write it out --
Fj omega to the i to the
j, which is omega i j.
And now, at this point in time,
everybody recognizes this.
This would be the discrete
Fourier transform of a vector.
This is an element of order n.
Usually, there's e to
the j and then an
element of order n.
Now it's in the finite field.
But what's the difference?
This would be the Fourier
transform.
So a code word would be the
Fourier transform of a vector
F. Let's just make sure it also
goes the other direction.
So I claim that Fl would be --
so what would be the Fourier
transform if it, indeed, is
the Fourier transform?
It is a minus, and then
it goes n minus 1
Fj omega minus jl.
So the question is
is that true?
Because that would
be the inverse.
Is that true?
Well, let's do what we do with
proofs of this type.
I need that space here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So let's do what we do with
proofs of this type.
That means we write it out.
That's another beautiful thing
about finite fields.
You never have to worry
about convergence.
So for the F, we just
plug that in here.
Sum, this would be --
what do we call it --
Fi omega to the ij.
So this would be Fj.
And then I want omega
minus jl.
So is that true?
Is the identity now true?
Well, we see two sums.
What do we do with two sums?
If we're compelled to exchange
the order, that's
always what we do.
So Fi goes out.
And then you get
omega to the --
what do we do --
i minus l times j.
We have this.
And so what is this?
How can we work this out?
Well, you know how to
express the sum.
So this part of the sum is
really just omega i minus l to
the n minus 1 minus 1.
Well, that's a standard
formula for summing
these things up.
But omega is an element
of order n.
Omega was an element
That's how we chose it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's what?
PROFESSOR: You multiplied
omega --
it's primitive in the
field, so omega --
we have omega da-da-da-da-da i
unequal to 1 for all i less
than n and omega n
is equal to 1.
So OK.
That's fine.
So it's an element of order n.
That means the n-th power.
We can interchange this.
So this is 1 to the some
power remains 1.
So 1 minus 1 is 0.
The denominator --
well, actually, we get
two results here.
If i is unequal to l,
then this is 0.
If i is equal to l, then this
was just the sum of n once.
So we get n here.
i equal to 0.
But n was q minus 1, the number
of non-zero field
elements because it was
primitive in the field.
And this one is just minus
1 in the field.
Because q, we compute q is the
power of the prime of p.
So that would be 0.
If we just come out
as minus 1, that
explains this minus here.
And we can get rid of
the question mark.
Look correct?
All right.
According to popular
vote, it is.
So what do we really
have here?
We have everything we want
from a Fourier transform.
We have a Fourier
transform pair.
We have a vector f, which we can
think of as being in the
frequency domain.
Then we have a vector F,
which is a Fourier
transform of that.
This one would be in the code
if the degree of this
polynomial here would
be less than k.
So now how can we understand
Reed-Solomon codes now from an
engineering point of view?
Classical --
what about band-limited
functions?
What do we know about
band-limited functions?
Because in a sense, the degree
less than k, this means that
Fi is 0 for all i
greater than k.
That's what it means.
So in a sense, it's nothing but
a band-limited function if
this is a frequency domain,
if you consider this as a
frequency domain.
So what do we know about the
band-limited function?
Well, if a function
is band limited,
it cannot be impulsive.
We know that.
It's a part of the frequency,
and the frequency domain is
inversely relational to the
support of the function.
So the whole idea of
Reed-Solomon codes, in a
sense, can actually be
understood, at least
intuitively, from Fourier
transform and the duality
between time and frequency.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was q a
prime number?
PROFESSOR: q is not prime.
q is a power of a prime.
q to the n.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There always is.
Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
or because for any q, there
would be always a primitive?
PROFESSOR: Why there's always
a primitive element
in the field --
yeah, sorry.
I thought you had gone
through that.
It's because the non-zero
elements in a field always
make up a multiplicative
group.
And it's always a cyclic
multiplicative group.
So it's a cyclic multiplicative
group.
And it's just the generator
of that group.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it was a --
PROFESSOR: It's the same
statement as saying, a cyclic
group has a generator.
AUDIENCE: If Fq, for example,
was a z, zq,
then q has to be prime.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, in order for it to be a
field, q has to be prime.
Right.
That's true.
But we are not worried
about --
There's also a beautiful theory
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
rings if this would not be a
prime, very nice theory,
becomes a little bit
more technical.
You see, more technical,
then more difficult.
I just wanted to give you this
correspondence on the Fourier
transform because it's, from an
engineering point of view,
a very nice insight.
One of the reasons one can
understand that Reed-Solomon
codes have a good minimum
distance is because it has a
transform of a band-limited
function.
So that's what I wanted
to say about the
Fourier transforms here.
I do not want to spend
too much time.
I have to get through
decoding here.
Since we have now this Fourier
transform correspondence, we
can do another thing.
We can, namely, say, well, F is
in the code if and only if
the Fourier transform --
so that was the back
transform here.
Also now, the code word, we can
interpret the code word as
a polynomial.
And the inverse transform
is just evaluating
it at an omega again.
F is in the code if and only the
transform of a code word
is 0 for all i greater than
k up to n minus 1.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So it basically
just means the support.
If this one is band limited,
then this one cannot have
arbitrarily small support.
That's what it means.
That's really all
I wanted to say.
i greater than k and
less than n.
So we have that F is in the
code if and only the
polynomial evaluates to 0
at a bunch of points.
Now that leads to something
interesting.
Because now we can say, well,
so what if we've just
construct our set of vectors F
so that they evaluate to 0
somewhere where we want
them to zero.
We construct them somewhat
differently than here.
And in particular, let's define
g as a product of i
equal k up to n minus 1 of
x minus omega minus i.
So it's a polynomial.
This is a polynomial which
satisfies this.
So in particular, we have g of
omega minus i is equal to 0
for all i less than
n less than --
I'm sorry --
and greater than k.
So this is a code word, right?
We are agreed this
is a code word?
Good.
So we found a code word without
going through this
here, without going through
the evaluation map.
We found it straight away.
But not only did we find this.
This has degree n minus k.
So maybe there's another
interpretation.
Now we can give a whole new
definition of the Reed-Solomon
code, namely, as a set of
polynomials, which are sort of
implicitly identified with a set
of vectors such that times
this g of x and h of x
is less then k again.
So what we have here, it's
again, you take a vector space
of functions the h.
It's a k dimensional
vector space.
And we multiplied with this g.
It's again a linear map, this
multiplication with a fixed
polynomial.
A linear map of this vector
space gives us, again, a
vector space of dimension k.
And all elements in this vector
space evaluate to 0 for
all omega to the minus i.
That's just the same
again, just the
Reed-Solomon code again.
So it's a very nice
complementary description to
the same Reed-Solomon code we
could define up here, we have
found again down here.
What is so nice about this?
Yeah, what do you think
is so nice about this?
About this description?
So now you have to think
as engineers.
AUDIENCE: You can still
evaluate it.
There, we have to evaluate it
at end points of function.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
This is so easy to implement.
So now we think a little
bit about encoder.
An encoder for a Reed-Solomon
code.
How would we do that?
You look at this here.
Hey, let's do this.
Let's exactly do this.
Meaning in VLSI, we do
something like --
and here, you would write
-- and this is
just a delay element.
This one would be g n minus k.
This one --
so these would be the
coefficients.
This polynomial, we can evaluate
once and for all.
We do that once before we
start our communication.
We evaluate that polynomial
once and for all.
We know these coefficients.
So these are multipliers which
multiply with those
corresponding coefficients.
And we feed into here the
coefficients of this
polynomial.
This is our information symbols,
which we simply feed
into this circuitry.
And into this circuit, out
comes F, out comes the
coefficient.
Polynomial multiplication.
If you show that to a
VLSI designer, they
are deliriously happy.
They say, you know what?
I implement you this thing.
I implement you in 5,000 gates,
which is close to
nothing nowadays.
Maybe not.
Maybe 10,000.
And there you get to the
second reason that
Reed-Solomon codes
are so extremely
important in practice.
On the one hand, they are MDS
codes, meaning they are about
as good as it gets.
And on the other hand,
they are algorithms.
They are circuitry for these
things whose cost is close to
nothing at least today.
When they were invented, that
was quite different.
In the '60s, that would have
not been implementable with
transistors on a board or
something like that.
But today, the cost is
close to nothing.
So the whole algorithmic
treatment of Reed-Solomon
codes is very well developed.
The encoder you could
do like this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Question about why
do you still require that
degree [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You don't
need to do that.
But then the mapping is not
one-to-one anymore.
Then the mapping is not
Let's put it other ways.
You want code words
of length n.
If the degree is larger,
you run over.
In order to still get a code
word, then you have to take it
modular x to the n minus 1.
And that would fold the
coefficients back.
And still, it gives you a valid
code word then, but this
is not one-to-one anymore.
Anyway, the short answer is if
you allow more, then they
become longer than n.
So what's the time?
OK.
So this is a nice encoder.
There even is a nicer encoder,
which I just want to give the
formula for.
The one reason that people still
have a problem with this
is it's not systematic.
People like to see the symbols
in the code words themselves.
They want the systematic part.
How could we achieve that?
Well, we go from the same
description here.
We say, well, let
h of x be given.
Then compute x to the n minus k
times h of x modular g of x.
So we divide this polynomial
by this polynomial g --
it has a name.
It's called the generator
polynomial.
We divide it by g.
And out comes some polynomial
r of x of some low degree,
degree less than g.
And degree r of x less than
n minus k in particular.
So and then we can
form a code word.
I claim F of x, no, F is --
and here we write r, and
here we write h.
The coefficient vector
of h and the
coefficient vector of r.
Why is that a code word?
Maybe minus here.
I'm always thinking
characteristic 2 anyway.
So why is this a code word?
Anybody, it's clear?
What this is in terms of F of
x is r of x plus h of x.
Oh, minus r of x.
That's because we wrote
it like this.
If we now take the F of x
modular g of x, well, this
part has degree low.
It's not affected by this
modular operation.
This would be minus r of x plus
this one, modular g of x,
which is r of x.
So the whole thing is 0.
If this is 0, that means g of
x is a factor of F. Hence,
it's a code word.
So we have a code word here.
And in the code word, pop up
our symbols right away, our
encoded information symbols
right away.
So we get some nice systematic
encoding going.
This division circuit by
g is pretty much the
same size as this.
It's not larger at all.
So there, we get beautiful
algorithms.
This is actually what's
implemented.
If we go to any disc drive
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], that is
usually what is implemented
in there, exactly this.
Algorithms.
Algorithmic treatment of
Reed-Solomon codes.
Do you have any questions
about any of this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about do any these
Reed-Solomon codes
map [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: They are
very costly map.
Usually, it depends a lot
on the application.
If you think disc drives,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] as just being
mapped, you take Reed-Solomon
codes over a characteristic 2.
Then each field element is
represented as a binary vector.
And that binary vector is mapped
into on-off keying.
Straight off the bat.
Nothing more fancy.
That is for disc drives.
And as you do this, the
satellite standard, where it's
mapped onto the 256-QAM field
elements [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it's many different ways.
Many different ways.
AUDIENCE: But to prove some
performance [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in the [UNINTELLIGIBLE], we need
to have mappings, right?
PROFESSOR: In order to prove
performance mode, we need to
have mappings.
And the Hamming distance bounds
that we get from here
give you bounds on the minimum
Euclidean distance.
If these are good bounds or
not depends a lot on the
modulation scheme.
And to be perfectly honest,
they usually are not.
They usually are not very
good, the bounds.
But it's a very difficult
problem to design a code or to
find a representation of the
fields that maps nicely onto a
modulation scheme.
Very difficult problem.
AUDIENCE: How do we know
how to think that
this is a good code?
PROFESSOR: The code itself is
excellent in terms of MDS, the
MDS property.
AUDIENCE: But why does
MDS mean good codes?
PROFESSOR: In respect
to modulation?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't.
It doesn't.
It's a bit like this.
It's really not easy to define
codes in Euclidean space.
So all that we do is we find
ways to do that and guarantee
some performance, some
sort of performance.
It's not easy to spread out --
I don't know --
2 to the 1,000 points
in 1,500 dimensions.
These would be typical
numbers really.
It's not easy.
And since that problem is
practically daunting, it's a
daunting task, you have to
develop all sort of crutches
to do that.
And this is really one.
So how to code MDS
codes playing a
part in this mapping.
If you want to be more fancy
about that, then you put a
convolutional code or some other
code also in there and
do a combine scheme.
I think Professor Forney will
talk about that more.
So here, it's just the
coding theoretic
groundwork of these things.
Anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of the [INAUDIBLE] n minus 1.
Close, very close [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, thanks.
So the algorithmic treatment
of Reed-Solomon codes is
extremely elegant.
And that's the second main
reason they are so much used.
It doesn't cost so much
to implement them.
Well, at least we've seen
that for the encoder.
That's a fairly small circuit.
So what about decoding?
Decoding.
How do we decode these things?
How could we possibly
decode them?
And I give you --
AUDIENCE: Fourier?
PROFESSOR: Right, that's true.
We could do the Fourier
transform.
But it doesn't help us so much
because we receive something.
And we receive a
vector, say, y.
From now on, let's say
x is a code word.
rs, right.
So x, it's usually a code
word from now on.
So this is a code word
plus an error.
So in particular, if we take the
Fourier transform, we take
the Fourier transform of the
code word, which is fine.
But then we get the Fourier
transform of the error.
So that destroys all the fun.
What else could we do?
Here's typical parameters
of a code.
255, 239, 256.
And you immediately see
that, OK, any sort of
group force is out.
How many code words
do we have here?
We have 8 to the
239 code words.
Now you don't want
to search that.
You definitely don't want
So how could we possibly
decode these things?
Turns out, to decode them in
some sort of optimal fashion,
maximum likelihood [INAUDIBLE]
actually, it's an
NP-hard problem.
Maybe last year, actually, it
has been shown that it's an
NP-hard problem to decode
Reed-Solomon codes.
It was known that decoding
in general was NP-hard.
But this is now the constraint
to Reed-Solomon
codes is still hard.
So what do we do?
Yes, OK, what do we do?
Let's say x is a code word.
We know that.
And set rate e, let's
just call it t.
So what happens if you
don't have an error?
Just thought experiment.
Thought experiment, if you don't
have an error, then yi
in all the positions is
equal to F of xi for
some F of x of degree.
In particular, since we
know the x's, we know
the positions --
sorry, oh, sorry.
That's not what I
wanted to write.
This is definitely not what
I wanted to write.
Let's keep that as c as a code
word and position i in c is
associated with xi
in the fields.
So meaning ci would
be F of xi.
That's really what I
wanted to write.
It makes more sense.
So thought experiment.
No errors.
Then yi is F of xi for some F.
If they ran no errors, then we
could just solve this linear
system of equations to find
the coefficient of F. And the
coefficient of F, say, were
our information circuits.
Is it clear that this is a
linear system of equations?
Yeah?
You could write it out as
y0, y1, y2 equal to --
and here we have f0,
f1, up to fk-1.
This is the linear system
of equations.
We know the xi's.
This is a linear system of
equation we have to solve.
If there are no errors,
then life is easy.
That seems to be reasonable.
So what happens if we
do have errors?
Somehow, we have to make sure
that the errors that we get do
not cause any problem for us.
And then we do something
very ingenious.
We define something called an
error locator which is a
polynomial x such
that x minus xi.
So it's a polynomial which is
0 in all error positions.
Well, you might say, we do not
know the error positions.
Well, OK, that's true.
Basically, this is, in the end,
what we want to find,
this polynomial.
But nonetheless, this
polynomial exists.
We can cast, actually,
the coding problem --
this is form 1 s.
Yes, what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's an
additive error model.
But you can cast pretty
much anything in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
If a position is altered, you
can always model that as if
something was added to it.
Decoding problem one is find
lambda of x of minimal degree
such that lambda of xi,
is 0 for all xi and
degree f less than k.
So I claim if you solve this
problem, namely, this is a
problem I give you.
I give you vector y.
Here it is.
Here is vector y.
And I give you vector x which
corresponds to the field
elements where you evaluated
that in order to
get the code word.
And then I said, given y and x,
find two polynomials lambda
and f such that f has maximum
degree k and lambda has
minimum degree, the smaller
degree possible so
that this is true.
And I claim this solves
the decoding problem.
This would solve the decoding
problem because once we have
found this, then we
can take lambda to
be the error locator.
And we can basically read
off the information
symbols from the f.
So this decoding formulation now
brings it, at least, into
the algebraic ground, brings
the whole decoding problem,
makes it something
algebraically.
But now the question becomes,
is that easy?
Or can we do this?
This problem here.
Do you see any hope for
solving this problem?
I guess the only
answer that --
OK, anybody says no?
Anybody does not see any hope?
All right.
This is great.
You all see hope here.
You all see hope here, which
seems to make you an
opportunistic bunch.
Not opportunistic.
What's the word?
Optimistic.
Optimistic bunch.
Let's put it like this.
What is the problem
in solving this?
It's not linear.
You get the coefficients
of lambda.
Multiply the coefficients
of f.
That whole thing becomes a
nonlinear problem, where we
say in the end, find the
solution to a set of
polynomial equations in a field,
which is a multivariate
polynomial equations, where the
coefficients of lambda and
f are the variables.
You can do that.
You could use techniques like
Grobner basis or so, and you
could do that.
But this is very difficult.
This is computationally
tedious.
So is that clear why this is
nonlinear, and why this is
hard to solve a nonlinear
problem here?
If not, then you have to say
something now, or forever hold
your peace.
So what do we do with
hard problems?
Once you take the optimization
classes, there's almost like a
reflex, there is a relax time.
We find the proper relaxation
of the problem.
Now the proper relaxation of
this problem is the following.
Decoding problem two.
Find lambda of x of minimal
degree such that --
it's almost the same,
almost the same --
lambda fi yi minus h of xi is
0, where the degree of h is
less than k plus
degree lambda.
So all that we did from this
formulation, which would give
us a clean solution to the whole
thing, right now, we
multiply in this lambda which
gives here, it keeps the
lambda times y.
And here, we get a new
polynomial, lambda times f,
which now has degree at most
k plus degree lambda.
And then we say, let's instead
solve this problem.
Let's solve this problem.
In particular, the question now
becomes well, we do not
require this anymore.
In this relaxed formulation,
we do not require this.
And that makes all
the difference.
It makes a world of difference
because this one --
look at it -- it's
a linear problem.
It's a linear program.
Why is it a linear problem?
Do you see it's a
linear problem?
Could you write down the
equation, the matrix equation?
It's pretty straight, right?
It's pretty straight.
You could, for example,
write it like, here, a
diagonal matrix yn.
Here, you would get something.
I think that seems
to be all right.
And here, just the evaluation
of the h.
So up to hk plus
degree lambda.
That's a linear system
of equations.
We can certainly solve this.
Well, we do not know really
what the lambda is, what
degree the lambda has.
But we're just hypothesizing on
all the possible degrees.
Well, we could say, OK, let's
assume the degree lambda is 0.
It's a constant, which would
be the same as saying there
are no errors.
Then we can look at the
system of equations.
Does it have a solution?
Well, yes, no.
If no, then we say, all right,
let's assume it's 1.
Well, does it have a solution?
Yes, no.
And so on.
Then we can move on.
So we can solve this
relaxed problem.
Does that help us?
It's nice to solve a
relaxed problem.
And in the end, we get two
vectors out of it, two
polynomials, lambda and h.
Does it really help us?
Well, yes.
Why?
Because --
let's put it like this.
We could easily check
if this is true.
Once we have our h, we can
easily check if this is true.
And if it is true, then we
have solved this problem.
If it is true, we have solved
this problem, which is the
problem we wanted to solve.
Good.
So is that all we need
to know about this?
We want to give guarantees.
We want to give guarantees that
we correct up to so many
errors, t errors, right?
So we have to guarantee that if
there are not more than t
errors, whatever t will turn
out to be, we can guarantee
that A, we will find
a solution, and
B, this will hold.
So two things to prove.
Is that clear?
That we have to prove
those two things?
So the first one first.
When do we find a solution?
And are we guaranteed
to find it?
Can we guarantee the existence
of a solution?
Well, when can we do that?
Let's look at this.
These are n constraints.
This is a system of linear
equations with n constraints.
If the total number of degrees
of freedom exceeds n, then we
are left with something
non-trivial after we solve the
system of equations.
So what's the total number
of degrees of freedom?
The number of degrees
of freedom --
so we get the lambda as a degree
of freedom, so which is
degree lambda plus 1.
And the other one is plus --
what is this one --
plus k plus degree lambda.
This is the total number of
degrees of freedom here.
And the reason is that this
one should be minus 1.
Sorry.
So this is total number
of degrees of freedom.
If this is greater than n,
then we can guarantee the
existence of a solution,
a nontrivial solution.
Then this thing will
have a solution.
It's a homogeneous system
of equations.
So the 0 is always a solution.
But that's not much
good to us.
So what do we get here?
Degree lambda.
To a degree lambda greater
than n minus k plus minus
1 or n minus k.
So the degree lambda greater
than n minus k over 2 -- does
that remind you of
anything here?
So this one is d
minus 1 over 2.
So very interesting, right?
Once upon a time, you learned
that if you make less than d/2
errors, you can correct that.
Very nice.
It pops up here.
It pops up here out
of the blue.
The reason that it pops up here
is, of course, the same
statement, that as long as we
stay within d/2 errors, we are
guaranteed to be able
to decode this.
So this is one.
So we know this one was
the number of errors.
If t is greater or equal
than this, then --
let's forget about the t.
If you proceed in this algorithm
hypothesizing the
degrees of lambda, once we've
reached this number in the
degree, there will
be a solution.
And we don't have to go
further than that.
So that's the first one.
So the second thing we have
to prove is that --
I shouldn't have done this --
that for some t --
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
standard degree of freedom
or less constraints?
PROFESSOR: You want to
guarantee a solution.
If you have more constraints
than degrees of freedom, then,
since it's homogeneous, you
usually would be stuck with a
zero solution.
Everything's 0, which
is no good to us.
It solves this problem, but
it doesn't give us any
information.
Is that all right?
AUDIENCE: Why does it have to be
the condition that degrees
of freedom has to be greater
than the constraints?
PROFESSOR: No, no, the
degrees of freedom --
well, OK, it's true.
We could get lucky.
We could have redundancy in
this system of equations.
And if we get lucky, that's
just for the better.
And actually, you can show that
you do get lucky if very
few errors happen.
Then this would have low rank.
You can show that.
But short of knowing much,
we want to guarantee --
I just want, at this point in
time, to guarantee that there
is a solution.
There is a non-zero solution to
this system of equations,
and the degree of lambda
is not more than d
minus 1 over 2.
There is a solution with a
degree of lambda being upper
bounded by this.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
less constraints?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no, no.
Once this is satisfied,
I guarantee
you there is a solution.
That means, the smallest
solution is guaranteed not to
be larger than that.
But there are, of course, many,
many more larger solutions.
There are many solutions of
larger degree here, which we
are not interested in since
we are interested
in the minimal degree.
So this is an upper bound on
the minimal degree lambda.
So now the other one.
So now we want to make the
statement about this one here.
When can we guarantee that our
relaxation didn't matter?
Despite our relaxation, our
solution that we find that in
the solution that we find
lambda divides h.
How can we guarantee this?
So how can we guarantee this?
Let's look at lambda xi
yi minus h of xi.
And we know this is
0 for all xi.
We know that.
We know that this guy here can
actually be written as ci plus
ei minus h of xi.
This is just expanding
this guy.
We also know that we can write
lambda xi times ci alone minus
f of xi lambda xi.
This is 0.
We know that this is true too.
AUDIENCE: For some f.
PROFESSOR: For some f.
The text is to f, so that
this is true too.
Then let's just subtract
these two guys.
Let's just subtract these
two things here.
And then we know that lambda
xi times ei --
so the first two cancel --
minus h of xi minus So we
know this is true too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sorry.
Just in time.
So what can we learn
from this?
So what is the degree of this?
What is the degree of this?
Well, this guy here --
we'll write it somewhere
else --
well, this guy had degree h was
less than n minus k plus
degree lambda less than
k plus degree lambda.
That's because we set up
that problem that way.
And we know that this
guy degree lambda.
We know that.
So this whole thing, let's call
it S. We know it's 0 for
degree S less than
degree lambda.
So why does that help us?
Well, let's look
at the vector.
Now let's look at all
the positions.
Let's look at the vector where
we had, in the vector, we have
lambda xi ei.
And now the fundamental
question.
What is the rate
of this vector?
At most?
What's the rate of
this guy at most?
It's 12 seconds,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Well, the rate of
this vector --
it's definitely not more than
the rate of the error.
Because every time the error
is 0, the rate drops out.
That's at most t.
What is the rate
of this vector?
So here we have a vector on
the other side, S of xi, a
vector on the other side.
What's the rate of this guy?
That's just the polynomial of
degree at most k plus degree
lambda minus 1.
So we have that the rate of this
vector is n minus k plus
degree lambda minus 1 plus
1 because of the minus.
AUDIENCE: Greater than
or equal to?
PROFESSOR: It's greater
than or equal, sorry.
Otherwise, I would have been in
trouble in a second here.
Yeah, so what does that mean?
So actually, this one is nice
to rewrite is equal to d n
minus t plus 1 d --
I really should have done it
like this in order not to --
it's d minus degree lambda.
So what can we learn
from that?
So we know this is true
for all the positions.
So if this is true for all
positions, then --
so if d minus degree lambda --
actually, this is t because
the rate was defined.
t was the number of errors.
And the error locator was just
defined to have degree t.
Right?
The error locator was just x
minus xi over all positions
where we had an error, so there
are t of those positions.
The degree of lambda
is equal to t.
So now we take this.
If d minus t is greater than
t, so if the rate of this
vector is greater than the rate
of this vector, then we
have a problem because
that cannot be.
Of course, by this identity,
the rate of these
two vectors is equal.
So what is the way out?
What's the way out?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if this is true, then S of
xi I claim has to be 0 and
lambda of xi times ei has
to be 0 too for all i.
That's the only way
out of this.
Because, obviously,
this was allowed.
If we really did find what we
wanted to find, namely, an
error locator here, then
this vector --
we said it has to
be less than t.
It can be less.
In particular, it can
be 0 if this is,
indeed, an error locator.
And if our relaxation
didn't matter --
that means the h that we
find factors as that --
if the relaxation didn't matter,
then S would be 0 too.
So that is a fair solution.
That's a possibility.
And if d minus t is greater than
t, then this proves this
is the only solution
that is feasible.
That's the only solution
you have.
So what that means is if t
less than t/2, then the
relaxation doesn't matter and h
of xi is equal to lambda of
xi times f of xi.
So is that clear?
That's two very simple, yet
nice ways to prove things.
Here, we guarantee
the solution.
Here, we guarantee that solution
is correct, namely,
if not too many errors happen,
if less than t/2 errors
happens, then relaxing the
original problem here to this
other form, which we
could solve, does
not change the solution.
That's what's proved there.
But about one-third
looks puzzled.
About half looks puzzled,
I would think.
Half looks puzzled.
Is there any way I can
explain that better?
Think.
Let's just go through
the steps quickly.
We had problem number one.
Problem number one, which is a
nonlinear problem, but you see
that if you could solve
this, you could solve
the decoding problem.
So you see that.
Anybody who doesn't see that?
All right.
You're smart guys.
If we can solve problem number
one, we are home free.
We have solved the
decoding problem.
Fine, we cannot solve it.
It's a nonlinear problem.
Well, we can solve it in
exponential time, but that's
little fun.
So we relax it.
We relax it into problem
number two.
All that we do, we multiply
things out.
And we do not require,
once we solve the
problem, this anymore.
Now we have solved
this problem.
We have solved this linear
system of equations.
And after doing so, we have
found lambda and h.
They are lying on the table
and looking at us.
Now what?
Are they any good?
In particular, since a priori we
cannot guarantee that this
relaxation didn't completely
destroy everything.
We have solved the system.
Now those two things are lying
on the table, looking at us,
and asking, what am I?
And in general, if there's an
arbitrary amount of errors
happening near the channel,
actually,
they do not mean much.
They do not mean much.
But now I claim that, well, if
not too many errors happened,
but if the number of errors is
bounded to be this, less than
half the minimum distance, then,
actually, I claim it did
not matter if we solved
the relaxation or
the original problem.
And the argument is
roughly this.
It goes like this.
Here, we start.
We have solved this.
We have two polynomials lambda
and h, so that this is true
for all xi.
We know that we can write
it like this.
That's just by definition
of yi, just
expanding the yi into this.
We know that this is true by
the definition of the code.
The ci is the evaluation of
f, of some polynomial f.
So we can write this just by
definition of the code.
So once we have these two guys
here, we can subtract them
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] here.
So we know that we have solved
the following problem.
We have found lambda and h.
So that there is guaranteed to
exist the polynomial f, so
that this whole thing, namely,
S of xi, that S is a
polynomial of degree
at most --
what did we have --
k plus degree lambda minus 1.
So that's a semi-hairy
step here.
Is that clear that we can
guarantee the existence of a
polynomial S of degree at most
k plus degree lambda minus 1?
So that this equation holds.
Once we have solved this,
we can guarantee the
existence of this.
That's what we're saying.
We can guarantee the
existence of this.
So now look at this.
If you write this out for all
i's and put it in a vector,
what's the rate of
this vector?
Well, it's at most t because
all the other e's are 0.
If lambda is an error
locator, it is 0.
But we do not know that yet.
All we know, it's at most t.
This is on this side, so that
vector has a rate at most t.
On this side, the rate of this
vector is at least this.
Just by evaluating a polynomial
of this degree,
this is the maximum number
of 0's we can get.
So now we have two equalities,
this one and this one.
But obviously, the two vectors
must be the same.
So how can these two vectors be
the same and still satisfy
these two inequalities?
Good question.
How can they be the same and
still satisfy this inequality?
If t is less than d/2, then the
rate of this vector would
have to be larger than
the rate of this.
If they are non-zero.
If they are non-zero, this would
have to be larger than
this because then d minus t
would be greater than t.
If this is true, this
implies this.
If this is true, this implies
this which implies that the
rate of this vector would be
larger than the rate of this
vector if they are non-zero.
But how can that be?
Answer is cannot.
Cannot be, hence,
they must be 0.
Both vectors must be 0
completely, which means this
is an error locator.
Because otherwise, this wouldn't
be 0, and this one --
where did I write it?
Somewhere I wrote it.
Where did I write it?
Oh, here.
So this S has to be 0 too.
If this S is 0, then h of xi is
exactly this, means factors
in the way you want it to.
So that's all I can say.
I could say it again, but it's
exactly the same words.
And there's a limited benefit
to even the repetition code.
So beautiful, right?
We have brought down the entire
decoding problem for
Reed-Solomon codes to solving a
linear system of equations,
namely, this one here or this
one in short form, which,
well, it's no problem at all in
the grand scheme of things.
And that's the other thing that
makes Reed-Solomon codes
so beautiful.
They're access encoding, they're
access decoding,
they're everything
that we want.
Let me do one more thing about
the decoding just to bring it
down a little bit, to talk a
little bit about complexity.
Solving this linear system of
equations has been subject to
research for 30 years,
40 years.
So it started out with an
algorithm which essentially
solved that linear
system directly.
It was formulated a
bit different, but
that's what it is.
It's called the
Peterson-Gorenstein-Zierler algorithm.
They realized it was a
polynomial time decoding
algorithm, a nice decoding
algorithm.
Then Berlekamp --
I should write down the name.
Berlekamp came up with a fast
algorithm and square algorithm.
Massey had his own formulation
of that algorithm, which was a
bit more streamlined I think.
Then there was a later version,
Berlekamp-Welch.
The complexity of these
algorithms is all roughly the
same, is all n squared roughly,
which solved this here.
And then there's
roughly nothing
happening for 30 years.
And after 30 years, then Madhu
Sudan made the next serious
dent in the decoding history
of Reed-Solomon codes.
So he found a way to solve this
problem even beyond half
the minimum distance.
And in hindsight, it's a very
nice and very simple trick
that he used.
So we started with
the following.
We started that, well, if we
have no errors, then the pairs
of points xi, yi lie
on this curve.
That's another way to formulate
what we said that yi
minus f of xi has to be 0.
We said, well, if there are no
errors, all the points that we
receive lie on this curve.
Because there are errors, we
have to multiply this with an
error locator and say this
is 0 for all xi, yi.
So this was problem
number one.
The relaxed form was lambda
xy minus h of x 0 xi, yi.
That's the way we do it.
So what did Madhu do?
Very clever.
He said, all that we have to do
is annihilate the effect of
the error right in this.
The whole reason for that lambda
was to annihilate --
so to take out the error
influence out of this
interpolation formula, to allow
for a few errors to
happen, which we can
put in lambda.
Well, Madhu said, well, what
about we take a polynomial in
two variables?
A polynomial in two variables,
then same thing.
If no errors happen, then all
the points xi, yi will lie on
that curve.
If a few errors happen, then
let's find a lambda xy, two
variables of some minimal
degree, some very small degree
so that this is still
satisfied.
And the problem is entirely
the same.
And this one, you cannot
solve either.
You cannot solve either.
But again, you can solve
the relaxation minus --
again, you can solve
the relaxation.
This is, again, a linear
system of equations.
And the coefficients of
lambda and psi now.
Once you solve this linear
system of equations --
actually, this one you can more
handily write simply --
now there is no way to
distinguish the y anymore
since both sides anyway
depend on y.
Find a polynomial in two
variables such that this is 0
for all xi, yi.
This is his central problem.
This is his relaxation.
Find a polynomial in two
variables, which he
evaluates to 0.
And then he has, essentially,
the same proofs we have here,
a bit more technical,
but not much.
I'm sure you can come up with
this if you sit down at home.
Let's put it like this.
There's no heavy machinery
in it.
There's no heavy math in it.
There's a lot of being clever
in it, but there's no heavy
math in it.
He can now guarantee that q of
xy, if t is less than n minus
square root of 2k --
is that right --
2kn, then you can guarantee
that y minus fx is
a factor q of xy.
The same thing we wanted
to guarantee.
And like I said, the proof is
very clever, but no heavy
machinery in it.
It's no heavy algebraic
geometry or any of
this stuff in that.
It's high school algebra.
Well, freshman college
algebra.
So that's what happens here.
It took 30 years and a computer
scientist to solve
that problem.
That was not all I wanted
to say, but that's
all I have time for.
There's one minute left, so
there's no point in starting
something now.
Do you have any questions
about any of this?
I should say that this 2 one can
get rid of, but that takes
a little bit more machinery.
The 2 one can get rid of, but
that's a bit more heavy.
All right.
So thanks so much.
That's it.